Thursday night football coming up jets
and Ravens tonight Daniel Jeremiah so
kind to join us on the phone right now
lead draft analyst for NFL Network DJ
listen to a little bit of your move the
sticks pod which is you know it's a
weekly ritual for me at this point I
mean it's just so good the hundreds of
thousands of downloads on the move the
stick spot chock full of information I
was uh that was not necessarily the
truth but it was very nice and I'll take
that as an introduction and and I'll run
with it my question is if I if I get one
guess on where rich is and what he's
doing can you tell me if I'm right sure
ooh
is he out is he out trying to recruit a
quarterback from Michigan a sleeping
over someone's as well played well
played
you know we can't comment on that DJ
speaking of quarterbacks buddy let me
ask you about Lamar Jackson I you've
been doing this a long time and you've
seen a lot of really good quarterbacks
have you seen one make the jump from
year one to year two and made the kind
of improvement that Lamar Jackson has I
don't think that I have and you know
it's one of those things it's been a
fascinating discussion all year long
with what he's done and you know so I
feel like sometimes we talk about you
know what did the personnel guys get
wrong that's what angle people take
other angle is you know the Ravens you
know had the courage to go get them
another angle is you know Greg Roman in
the system and the tight ends and at
building this thing around him and I
think sometimes like dude this is let's
just let's look at the obvious here
Lamar Jackson put in a ton of work and
improves as a passer from one year to
the next
deserves all the credit in the world for
that and he'd be the first to tell you
that when he came in you know he was a
work in progress and I think sometimes
like we're just we're trying to find
this this storyline instead of just
let's just give him credit for for you
know a very very talented football
player who put
a lot of time and made himself a better
player and and it's obvious to see what
he's done it's been incredible I'm he's
first in the league in touchdown passes
he's fourth in passer rating he only has
six interceptions zero in the red zone
he's completion percentage at 66% right
around the same as Russell Wilson and to
your point about improvement you know he
had just six touchdown passes last year
and you know six or seven starts his
completion percentage was 58% it seemed
like every other ball he threw last year
was kind of a duck he didn't know where
it was gonna go and here he is this year
operating inside and outside of the
pocket at a high level as well as any
other quarterback is in football who do
we give the credit for it you've
obviously it's Lamar he put him you give
him a ton of credit but in terms of
molding the system to him is it is it
more Harbaugh is it more Roman who's
most responsible for making the system
the team the framework work around his
skill set I think that from that way you
phrase that it's a combination of
Harbaugh being open to something new and
then Greg Roman you know deserves the
bulk of the credit in terms of crafting
the scheme you know and look here at the
COS has gone out and got the pieces that
they needed it was a complete whole
vision that they all had but Greg Roman
has more intel on how to to operate in a
you know option based you know
quarterback run game way than any other
play caller and I felt because of his
experience with Kaepernick and what they
are able to kind of play with what they
liked what they didn't like what works
what didn't work there in San Francisco
and he's taking it and just kind of
evolved and grown it from that from that
slot so Greg Roman a lot of creative
creative credit there but I still think
again I come back to add and I mean
Lamar Jackson in college fifty four
point seven percent completion fifty six
point two fifty nine point one now what
does that tell you those are all lower
completion percentage but it tells you
that each and every year he got better
right and we saw it last year from where
he was in the NFL to where he is this
year this kid just continues to work and
he's self-made and
you know I again I think we can talk
about all the stuff around him but man
let's not lose sight of the fact this
guy worked his butt off and and he's a
dynamic athlete who's really made
himself into a good quarterback he is so
fun to watch after losing a Kansas City
in Cleveland early in the year he's
beaten Pittsburgh Seattle the Rams and
Buffalo on the road and oh yeah San
Francisco in New England at home I
honestly think he doesn't play another
game this year they've already clinched
a playoff spot you would crown him the
MVP Steve Young the last quarterback to
lead the MVP and touchdown passes and
quarterback rushing yards and back then
he only had 293 yards lamar's on pace to
have over 1200 yeah I mean he's going to
be the MVP now not to throw you know I
throw water on the fire here but but you
know the last couple games against very
good defenses mind you in San Francisco
and Buffalo they're under 300 yards
offense right so you know now I just
like today let's just let's take a step
back now they still have a lot of work
they need to do I think the schedule
they're gonna be fine get to the regular
season but once they get to the
postseason you know you're gonna see a
Chiefs team that I believe that'll be
the third time they will have seen this
offense right they saw it last year and
then saw it again this year
they're two-and-oh against them so
that's a team that has some experience
with them if they run into New England
again you know Belichick is gonna make
some adjustments haven't got a chance to
see that for the first time earlier this
year so it's you know I think a lot of
people have just kind of said all
they're in there they're in the Super
Bowl like now they look this is so it's
so interesting here in the AFC how this
plays out considering teams got a chance
to see this I saw it last year doing the
charger games from what that looked like
the first time the Chargers saw it so
what it looked like the second time and
it was a lot easier for those guys to
kind of get a handle on it now he's
still paid plate and second off of that
game but you can't simulate it on a
practice field you just can't it's it's
so different and he is so explosive it's
so fast you don't know what it's like
for you get out there and see it
firsthand
well it's your point you had twenty and
twenty four points last two games
against the 49ers and the bills but both
of those still wins for the Ravens which
i think is pretty impressive the poll
question today DJ if you had a five-year
window to win who's your quarterback
Lamar
Shawn Watson mahomes or Russell Wilson
oh man a five-year window those are all
great options so watching that question
hey Jake
I yeah that's a good question I know you
didn't come up with it I'm gonna go you
know I'll probably I would probably go
mahomes I would go homes and and one of
the reasons with mahomes having seen him
a lot over the last couple years like
when they played the Chargers over in
Mexico City he's he made yes three runs
over 20 yards and I think you know he's
not you know Lamar Jackson Sean watts in
terms of mobility but he can move around
and he can use his like if he needs to
and he's just got the most ridiculous
you know right arm that I've ever seen
what he can do there so I think that
would be for five years knowing that
he's only going to continue to get
better I think he'd be my pick all right
let's go to these college quarterbacks
now I lead draft analyst for NFL Network
you're watching these guys and putting
out great little clips on Twitter all
season long Joe Burrell already named
the AP Player of the Year I think he's a
lock to win the Heisman
is he a lock to be the first pick in
your mind he's a lock you know I was you
know it's tough to say a lock these days
but I think he's a I feel like he's a
lock to be the first quarterback the
first overall pick I would say the
favorite because it looks like the
Bengals will have that sick right I can
make an argument about chase young you
know but you know it nine times out of
ten maybe ten times out of ten if you
need if you need the next quarterback
you will take a really good quarterback
over a great anything else and that's
what the decision they're gonna have to
make so I would say he's the he's
definitely the favorite to be the first
overall pick I said earlier in the show
that I think to a tongue of law is gonna
be a top five pick assuming everything
checks out with the hip after the
surgery in his rehab is on time this was
a generational talent according to many
do you feel like he's a top five pick or
Albert Brewer said he feels like he
could slide to the middle - even late in
the first round I've talked to probably
three or four GM's
the
could be in the quarterback market that
are not going to be picking in the top
10 that have jokingly told me like what
do we have to put out there to get this
guy to fall like what do we need to do
here like let's sound like play that
game I'm not doing that but they're like
I don't st. Alberts doing that but I'm a
sailor there's a lot of people that are
your wishfully hoping that somehow to is
you end up falling you know as long as
there's you know from I'm not a doctor
but it sounds like as long as there's
good blood flow to his hip that that's
something he's going to recover from and
if that's the case maybe there's too
many teams that need quarterbacks he's
too talented I don't envision any way
that he's going to fall too far in the
draft who's the next best guys is it
from as a Jacob Eason
I love the Utah State kid jordan love
who his numbers don't look good his
numbers do not look good on paper but he
is he is intriguing with his skill set
man because he's big athletic he's got a
huge arm he's a lot like drew Locke and
we're seeing Locke really come on and
play well but but I would say you know
you're talking about pretty clear I
think it's burrow then to me I think
it's 2a then I think you know teams have
a little different order there I still
think Herbert will end up being the
he'll end up being the third guy to go
and then now you get into the you know
Jordan love the next three guys Jordan
love you're gonna see what happens with
Jacob Eason if he ends up coming out he
he could be one that could shock people
how high he could go out of Washington
and I think from is a little bit behind
those guys problem dad hasn't had a
great year I want to move back to the
NFL for a minute because there are such
an incredible crop of quarterbacks that
are going to be on the market this year
you just look for agency think
quarterbacks who would you rather
Tannehill Rivers Brady
ooh I'm gonna answer that question that
I'm going to go back with a question so
Tannehill Rivers Brady if I have a team
that's wedded ready to win right now
like we are ready to go right now I
think I would probably lean towards
Brady with a short-term
and then I think when you're looking at
the long drawn-out period of time if
you've got a young team that's kind of
still growing and you've got to be
competitive for a longer period of time
I think you go Tannehill but here was
the question that I talked about on our
podcast today which I'd love to get
Brachman and on this yeah we said go
back to 2017 if you gave the Patriots a
do-over knowing all this happened since
and there were three straight Super
Bowls you know one two of them would you
would you have traded Brady at that time
instead of Jimmy Garoppolo wasn't that
the joking line the John Lynch said to
Belichick is Brady available well yeah
well you know the funny thing is I you
know you talk to people around the
league and they said they thought that
because Belichick loved Garoppolo so
much that you know you'll have an easier
time getting brady than you would get in
Garoppolo from Belichick right and and
then you just go back with so we were
kind of going through it like what if
okay my thing was the question I don't
know it you know like the twenty-eight
three come-from-behind win over Atlanta
that was a Brady special maybe Garofalo
doesn't pull that off the next year you
lose the Eagles in a Super Bowl I don't
think that changes anything
no no but last year you trying to tell
me that they don't win that's what ten
three Super Bowl they still win that
Super Bowl with Jimmy Garoppolo would
you agree I think so yeah I think so I
don't know man to arrange another six or
seven you got six or seven more years
now going forward with Jimmy trouble it
to me it was like that was the one time
like the Patriots way the Patriots you
know the way they've done business
forever would have been to get rid of
Tom Reed right exactly they did it with
all their great players they cut lawyer
Milloy they trained Willie McGinest
they traded Deion Branch and then got
him back for a lesser pick than they
acquired I I don't know it's tough to
say when Brockman I use I use the movie
reference and Helly you appreciate this
because we're all similar age that's
like Point Break when they did they had
to do though they'd never go to the
vault it's been 99 and I go yeah you're
breaking your rules they broke their own
rule but they got two rings out of it
that I know and that's my question my
question is would you have still got
those two rings with Garoppolo it's a
fascinating conversation
I think you
get one of them I'm not so sure you
would get two but do you have a window
with this defense the way it is now
going forward with Jimmy for the next
six or seven years that you might get
one that Tom's not going to be around to
get going forward are we convinced Jimmy
Garoppolo as that dude it was a
different story
DJ wasn't it about a month ago I know he
doesn't lose football games things I
know yeah hey DJ have you ever had a do
your job segment shot about you when
you're an advanced scout for a sector
you know I did not but can I don't know
I don't even know what's been said on
that because I haven't really watched
ice no people were up in arms about it
it was so dumb to me because there's no
advantage to that whatsoever this is
whatever the Patriots you think of them
or what they may have done in the past
this is 100% harmless there's no upside
there they they the way I understand it
they're filming them as a pro scout I've
done that advance before you get there
during the game you pull out your
binoculars you look at the signals to
see what personnel grouping there and
meaning there and you know 21 personnel
12 personnel just a number of running
backs and tight ends that are coming on
in the field I would write down all my
paper a fist means 12 personnel two
fingers that means 22 personnel you give
that sheet of paper to your you put in
your advance scouting reports to the
coaches that are up in the booth the
next week when they see the signal they
know what's personnel to match on the
field you're not getting their play call
you don't know what they're gonna do you
know schematically we just know who's
trotting out onto the football field and
so when they were said this was them
filming him doing his job I was like all
that and easy misunderstanding because
the video guy doesn't know he's like
what are you doing in advance well I
look at the signals and I write them
down and I give them to the coaches well
let's grab some b-roll let's get some
video of the signals right there's no
competitive advantage that you're going
to gain because they're getting all that
information through the binoculars yeah
this is some third-party freelancer that
was hired
you know from somewhere in Ohio to go to
Cleveland to shoot the piece advance
scout Daniel Jeremiah breakin the
Patriots video spy gate situation down
for us love that DJ hit me with our
there's there's three games that are
intriguing to me this weekend you have
the Texans and the Titans Rams at the
Cowboys and the bills
at Steelers which one of those three
games is is most interesting to you
to me it's Titans Texans and I don't
just say that because I'm talking to the
preseason voice of the Tennessee Titans
I actually do find that to be very
entertaining the way that the Tennessee
is playing with Tannehill the way they
run the ball and the total like
jekyll-hyde Houston Texans who man their
ceiling is so high but their floor is so
low you just don't know what you're
going to get from them and they play
each other twice or I don't think
they've played so I think they've got
two meetings coming up here down the
stretch to really kind of decide that
division so that's what I'm keeping my
eye on and then selfishly I'm telling
you don't I know I call the game don't
sleep on the Chargers and the Vikings
play in the Minnesota Vikings the
Minnesota Vikings that's a that's a
scary game because the Chargers haven't
lost a game by more than a score all
season long they're healthy with Derwin
James and Russell Oh [ __ ] back in the
lineup they've got absolutely nothing to
lose that's a little bit of a that's a
scary one for the Vikings in my opinion
yeah I feel like that's a different
looking defense with Derwin James back
in the lineup and that was a good point
DJ I've actually forgotten that they
play the Texans in two out of the last
three games you don't see that very
often
among division opponents he is Daniel
Jeremiah lead draft analyst for NFL
Network longtime NFL scout good friend
of mine move the sticks podcast check
that out it's a good listen he always
drops knowledge DJ thanks buddy
you're the best and brockman del to fo
good to catch up with you guys and see
you later goodbye Daniel Jeremiah one of
the very best in the business for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app